right and firing his weapon to protect
his partner the moment I pulled the
trigger
I felt fear when I walked around I saw
him stick down on the ground
I felt horror seeing her there I knew in
an instant that I was wrong the depth of
my error has only increased from that
moment on working to save her life
and watching her slip away is a feeling
I can't explain I can say it it leaves
me sad he leaves me numb and a feeling
of incredibly lonely but none of that I
know those words capture what it truly
feels like it shouldn't matter but mr.
foucha check was a fine person
her fiance and her family are also such
fine people and I feel worse because of
that I live with this and I'll continue
to live with this I call this tragedy
and it is my burden
I wish though that I could relieve that
burden others feel from the loss that I
caused I cannot and that is a troubling
reality for me I will think about miss
Ruth cheque and her family forever he
does not take personal responsibility
for making the erroneous decision to
fire her with regard to count two I
hereby commit to the Commissioner of
Corrections for a period of 150 months
you will see of credit for the 41 days
you have spent in custody since this
offense the situation any other way
Muhammad Muhammad nor I hereby remand
you to the custody
the Commissioner of Corrections